tu as bien mec ça va super super super
bien c'est parce que plaisir le être
invité ici paraître t'imagines si google
est en train de se dire qu'est ce qu'ils
font et c'est mal et si on ne faisait
pas les bien bel et bien de plus ce que
veut des toiles de tous que celui
d'austin my name mais non très bien
ouais super super super je suppose être
humain n'est bien manger bien et très
bien merci beaucoup pour cet accueil
t'inquiète pas ce que est ce que tu veux
te présenter hugo ok là je loue présence
je m'appelle du coup j'ai une chaîne qui
s'appelle hugo décrites
l'idée c'est de décrypter l'actualité
pour les jeunes principalement pour les
mecs sûr sur youtube en tout cas et en
gros je fais des vidéos en cinq minutes
qui décrypte des faits d'actualité donc
là enfin un peu tout et on va faire le
décryptage de chaque programme du
programme de chaque candidat un peu tout
mais pas n'importe quoi et pas
d'apporter quoi aller et après je fais
aussi des interviews des candidats à la
présidentielle que
j'en ai fait quelques-uns des revers de
la droite mais c'est d'enfermer revue et
augmentée les interviews augmenter son
rôle ya des textes étaient bull qui
s'affiche
non il parle d'un certains trucs pour
apporter informations si tu comprends
pas un truc comme ça c'est expliquer
l'idée s'écoute tout le monde même un
mec qui connaissent rhin puisse
comprendre une thermos et la
vulgarisation dax puis quoi ouais ouais
de cryptage pour les jeunes pour voilà
je pense que pendant les présidentielles
c'est assez important quand on dit que
donc voila voila voila vous êtes qu'il
faisait
oui car avant je vous conseille d'aller
voir et surtout par même si vous aimez
salle aux cris ça aussi c'est un truc
est assez complémentaire de ce que fait
hugo finalement parce que jean hieaux
fait des trucs cours de cinq minutes
ouais et à côté des interviews
politiques puisque vous trouverez pas
chez moi alors hugo on va traiter une
question là on va se demander
t'imagines si les élections
présidentielles avait lieu sur youtube
tout haut bon bah je connais principe h
que le principe est de se regarder en
face à des jeux directeur aujourd'hui
c'est un peu une petite région
mais du coup on a besoin que dans ces
téléphones à dos comme moi j'ai un match
écoute tu peux ranger de certains cas
pas qui fait après je le fais je crois
que regarder l'émission mais je sais que
d'aller chez guerlain téléphone etc on a
eu le même document on n'a jamais fait
ça dans aucune n'avait jamais regardé je
découvrais que les émissions c'est à
chaque fois un seul téléphone
balou rico ok ok c'est bon quoi
ça commence bien tu imagines si ya pas
encore de génériques mais ça arrive
alors les électeurs choisira le
président selon sa personnalité ou
plutôt celle qui montre et non selon
leur programme
le niveau depuis ta clique définirait le
président pour être dans les tendances
dépenses d'appairer youtube et des lois
se créeront pour empêcher cela pour moi
pourquoi est-ce-que pourquoi ce que l'on
paie enfin poissonsvotre est plus pour
la personnalité sur youtube peu sur ses
marges étaient sur moi je me demandait
déjà si ce n'était pas déjà un peu le
cas quoi je dire sur à la télé quoi
former
mais là maintenant oui les gens il va
rentrer ne connaissent pas vraiment les
programmes way que les grandes lignes
mais entre deux candidats ce qui va
différencier c'est plus franchement je
vais même plus loin pour moi sur le jeu
que je serai mieux on parlerait plus du
programme parce que tu vois mélenchon
ouais on prend l'exemple de mes enfants
quand même pas parce que parce que là il
s'avère qu'il est sur youtube mais ça
pourrait être les quatre tous les
candidats mélenchon sur sa chaîne mais
c'est le cas des autres ceux qui sont
sur youtube bah il parle en rien un peu
de com tu as quand il fait vrai elle
soit ghetto mais sinon il part de son de
son programme soit pendant vingt minutes
le mec qui parle de son goût de ces
mesures de ce qu'il veut faire de sa
position sur tel ou tel truc alors que à
la télé c'est toujours caricature avec
moi ça me fout en mode comme mélenchon
donc c'est le mec de gauche donc vous
allez faire mec pas content tu vois vous
criez vous faites du truc parce qu'en
face de vous on met un on met un chef
d'entreprise et du coup il y aura un
clash et il ya passé sur youtube je
pense ça serait plus sage et garçons
espace à chaque fois son espace en fait
c'est ça du coup les mecs qui sont-ils
quoi ils sont et au delà de ça le mec
parlait de [ __ ] à cliquer en vrai moi je
pense je me demande je me demande donc
tu imagines si l'on retrouve des
questions je me demande si ce ne serait
pas une bonne chose dans le sens où ça
créé des mécanismes pour nous intéresser
genre à leur programme par exemple
android il ferait des efforts de
communication doit elle pas maintenant
nous allons y aménager leurs programmes
de manière d'une manière qui nous nous
donne envie de nous intéresser à leur
programme en quoi donc si la cisaille va
faire ça jacques rey le risque c'est que
ce que ça serait vraiment rien à [ __ ]
et ils vont être en mode à bas l'idée
c'est de faire des abonnements gagner
des abonnés donc tant pis du programme
juste on plaît on vous fait rire aussi
serait-ce que la même du coup on parle
pas pour la mairie qui ment
arias cerise après ouais ça serait une
question de responsabilité de chacun de
mes agents s'abonnerait frégate fin tu
vois c'est vrai de s'abonner vraiment
pour les idées ou quoi mais ça j'avais
une question d'ailleurs qu'est ce que
est ce qu'on considère qu' on n'a droit
qu'à un abonné à un abonnement vodafone
à plusieurs personnes
ça s'est assez vite ça c'est énorme ça
c'est énorme mais dieu que j'en sais la
règle de youtube s'est tu peux des
abonnés c'est assez énorme et mais moi
je trouve ça génial parce que ben je
sais pas il a failli à peut-être un
problème le changement
il importe que tu as beau n'être
désabonner way et jean ronald jusqu'au
premier tour jusqu'au à la clôture du
truc du décompte pour changer d'avis du
coup traitée en france par an en plus ya
pas de sondages et dans l'ohio c'est
presque un sondage entouré genre si tu
vois les idées wahaha sociales dépassées
il en bar d'après cbs
je compte m'acheter pas mais moi en me
de lui le côté genre sondage informel et
les mecs qui cachent leur jeu et imagine
dans le candidat surprise à la fin je le
regard plein de gens qui s'abonnent pour
lui genre je sais pas ils me tuent pour
la hache je crois que pouvaient pas
jusqu'à me cacher son jeu j'ai pas ces
pages aurait un côté fait une percée à
la fin genre tel talent mais qui remonte
genre et d'herbe dans les dernières
heures avec panique bas et puis même
makhoul algo imagine la lgo youtube se
met à pousser un gars là on va même plus
loin
franchement ce moment par le rappel sur
ma part à l'origine du double garde à la
garde de choisir si jamais on n'en parle
pas tous laïques et si les élections
étaient sur youtube ou là ou alors je me
prépare y aurait des top 10 des lois qui
vont se passer
la 9ème est incroyable prend qu il se
fait élire surtout présenter gones
secure blog mois a prise dans live si tu
veux que je te représente je supprime ma
chaîne situtaion pas mal à me dois je
rend l'argent des taxes
si les élections avaient lieu sur
youtube ça obligerait tout le monde à
avoir un compte google pour pouvoir
s'abonner et voter pour le politicien
qui veut voir président donc tout le
monde aurait accès à un ordinateur ou à
internet pour pouvoir voter tel même que
l'état mettra en place des sessions
d'apprentissage de youtube pour que tout
le monde puisse voter correctement ou
bien des associations d'autres votants
ou des partis politiques mais les
personnes qui ont du mal avec un payet
et youtube risque de galérer à un max
pour choisir un participant comme
certaines personnes âgées qui ont du mal
avec les technologies la majorité des
votants auraient entre 18 et 35 ans et
qui sont plus souvent sur youtube du
coup on meurt on sera honorée soit
mêlant donc l'a fait du coup on aurait
soit mélenchon ou mâcon comme président
par un temps quasi
bah oui oui dans mes classes oui oui
allez ça chez moi je trouve ça très
intéressant le coup d'avoir des assauts
et tous qui bagdad est un combat
épuisant que je pense qu'on aurait un
bulletin
c'est en rien un document deux du
gouvernement jean reconnaître un compte
google bing et de la petite voix les
cinq comptes à suivre pour suivre
l'actualité hugo des cryptes scellées ce
nom très très bien sûr mais non en vrai
on passe à autre chose
non je veux les non-membres année un
truc qui est intéressant c'est que au
delà du fait qu'ils auraient qui galère
un peu de fatigue délégué je pense
qu'ils n'auraient pas la même
utilisation de leur compte que nous
c'est à dire que tu en as dit on a droit
à plusieurs votes ouais je pense que les
jeunes
il sera à fond quoi ils voteraient pour
plusieurs personnes il réagirait il
ferait monter des trucs en tendance et
tout est en gros genre au delà du fait
que oui il y aura y arriver en médiation
en parallèle des voyeurs et les mecs qui
genre est sur une forme par exemple
serait alors ma chance c'est sans sa
vidéo à tel moment voilà qu'on se
mobilise à paris notamment
ouais et du coup tu vois je pense que
les normes du coup non seulement séduire
c'est le genre non seulement aux quais
les vieux vont peut-être moins voté ou
voilà parce qu'ils savent pas comment
faire et ça ça les fait chier mais à
l'inversé des jeunes vont être hyper
lâcheront plus des rejets vont voter ils
dont ils vont même pas manipuler du
trayon s'ils vont manipuler presse que
l'élection doit oui ils vont pousser des
trucs en tendance ils vont genre en fait
ils prennent en main un truc et c'est un
peu dangereux
c'est à dire que je leur ferais tu vois
il se fixait des mecs bien organisés
pour un pour un mec qui poussait tout en
ouvrant ses déserts qu'en fait en fait
ce qu'on reproche parfois aux médias tu
vois sur le contrôle des temps par
orienté sur qui met en avant et ça ira
là ce serait pas une décision de médias
une décision des gens seraient les gens
qui se mobiliseraient pour mettre en
avant telle personne pour qu'on parle de
telles personnes
mais du coup ça il ya un côté antho
dangereusement sur pour moi moi ça me
fait un peu peur le côté finalement bas
tout le monde n'a pas le même temps
sarah leur toit bah ouais mais mal mais
je pense que du coup enfin je peux faire
le visuel soit amusant
les premiers arrêtés avec les veaux faut
bien se passer ou sans rendre un bail
technique le csa le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel fois il est lâchement pour
contrôler et en paroles et/ou à la
télévision et le problème c'est que sur
youtube on a plus de savoir chacun à sa
chère ici à la fois ses besoins à la
fois ça peut être chaud quoi tu peux
avoir des mecs qui arrivent à gérer très
peu aux remarques ça fait une
compétition douze quoi j'ai pas acheté
s'il bonne chose oh merde on aurait
droit au watt's in my back de marine le
pen l'horreur
oh merde on aurait droit au vote in my
back de marine le pen il n'y aurait plus
de sondages non plus les candidats
peuvent se référer aux commentaires en
gros youtube sur une plateforme pour
sonder l'opinion publique avec un pad
bien plus large et complet et donc
représentatifs
peut-être aussi du coup il n'y aurait
plus limite d'âge ou du moins qu'elle
serait abaissée
comme il ya beaucoup mineurs sur youtube
et surtout moins d'abstention car pour
une fois ce sera plus facile de voter se
convaincre qu'ils sont subsiste comment
voter blanc oh bah tu vois ta nasa des
recensions simpson blanc du tableau
ouais il fait les choses propres sur le
plan de mai mais pour le coup le
évidement les sondages les sondages et
garçons disais tout à l'heure c'est
énorme ça [ __ ] tu sais en direct en
fait c'est vrai qu'il a prouvé son ce
serait quoi
mais enfin c ur genre ça change tout
ouais il toutes les stratégies des
politiques
et ça ça me fait penser à un truc que je
pense que tu vas y aurait on parle d'un
truc en politique fondation vous ramener
ça en france c'est lutter de front
républicain c'est genre c'est le ps et
les républicains
ouais non on ne peut pas du fn pourquoi
on appelle à voter l'un pour l'autre et
ça en gros il pourrait faire sur youtube
donc temps réel tu vois c'est que c'est
dès le premier tour
s'ils voient ils s'ils voient qu'il ya
le fn dans un camp d un parti qui sait
pas qui montent ils font ok les gars ok
on mise tout on se rassemble tous sur ce
candidat
il y aurait des appels au vote qui
change dans un truc tu vois selon la
tendance genre là il ya un mec qui
montent encore la loire et quoi ces sept
dans la soirée on me dira migratoires et
des séries scop est tous avec des
intentions y aurait des trucs genre en
direct le touchant choix je les mecs
c'est à des courts clips à la télé sont
leurs [ __ ] temps sur youtube du coup
tous montrés habiles et graphique qui
s'afficherait et ou en mode
la progression du touquet et tout ça
c'est trop dernier moment
mais en fait ça serait genre sur plus
d'une soirée plein de gens qui seront
monopolisées devant leur a endigué nous
tous on serait tous derrière nous hors
d'elle on serait tous là chacun avec son
ordi segment de google enfin son compte
google via sa carte d'identité a changé
de boîte et tout ça serait énorme c'est
énorme ça serait un croyant ainsi ouf
c'est ce que tu vois ce genre diable je
n'ai pas voir dans une livrée c'est ça
je vais faire appel à lui et de le vivre
ici je passe et est suivie et j'en avais
déjà eu des élections américaines
je passe tu as vu les sondages en direct
pour mamie mais c'est avec les trucs de
new york times
tu voyais là or c'était des dépôts des
pourcentages de chances que tel ou tel
candidat l'emporté et toute la nuit
enfin moi je regardais cette fois j'ai
passé la nuit sur ce graphique et sur
les trucs des trucs qui changeait en
temps réel et des vins à dire on a passé
en france parce que ça à 20h pile des
résultats ou sur radio mon avance sur
twitter je mets ça sort dédicace à vatan
mais si tu poses ckoi radio la radio
c'est c'est un bon buteur au départ que
j'ai lancé sur twitter
loulou j'annonce avec une équipe
maintenant les résultats des élections
avant 20 heures sur la chaîne radio
londres et depuis c'est un média ont
écrit voilà je précise que le mec avait
14 ans quand il a créé sous 14h15 on
voit la place mais c'est l'autre mais
oui du coup on the valley tendance en
direct et d'en face tu aurais des
alliances et aux derniers lui auraient
détruit genre bassens et non à cette
phrase est simple fait des élections
directes comme ça youtube serait le lieu
de la politique
bien avant les journaux télés etc je
pense pas que ce soit quelque chose de
mauvais en soi j'aurais plus il y aurait
plus l'intermédiaire du journaliste du
plateau télé des questions préparées
qu'il crée une distance entre politique
et le citoyen âgé pas d'accord c'est
tout se passait sur youtube les
politiques parlerait plus directement
aux gens sans détour sans artifice comme
youtube heures qui fait une faq
je suis pas d'accord là je vais être
obligé de mettre mon veto moi je je
pense que c'est bien qu'il l'ait
politique est une chaîne et puisse
parler directement parce
qu'effectivement ça nous permet de
développer des sujets et de d'en parler
en mode battue avant vrai comme
mélenchon mais là et maintenant il ya
d'autres candidats plus que mais
l'enfant mais d'en parler librement
pendant 20 minutes et d'exposer leurs
trucs parce que la télé tu as une des
règles strictes et toujours raison peu
de temps de parole et roux donc ça c'est
bien en même temps
alors que ça c'est à dire que le mec
peut dire d'expert sur sa chaîne mais
qui peut dire des conneries il ya
personne pour le contredire
il peut raconter n'importe quoi il ya
personne dans le pour moi le
pourrissement voire en plateau télé chez
moi journaliste loubna el mekki ça roule
et partant c'est important donc à ce que
celle ci qui relance au bon moment ça
c'est lui aussi qui sait le programme du
candidat qui sait les failles et voilà
les points c'est les trucs oui la torre
uchishiba c'est le bon choix et ce après
ouais c'est ça ce que j'aime et c'est ce
que j'aurais risqué l'ex d'accord ou
d'ailleurs le journaliste qui se demande
qui fait la polémique à la télé
cherchent la petite phrase qui cherche
toi la question que tu poses à des
candidats qui est un vieil tout à son
propre enfant
si les connaissent ils les connaissent
pas non ils connaissent pas ils
connaissent même pas les thématiques des
fois je leur donne en mode sociaux est
une thématique très appréciée georges
juste envie qu'on a un vrai débat dessus
aujourd'hui n'ont peut-être parler de ça
donc c'est des gens parfois tu les coins
sur des trucs bas sa dépendance à des
vents franchement c'est au fur et à
mesure j'ai besoin de m'améliorer genre
au début première interview dans le
maire g j'ai pas réussi je pense à
relancer tu vas mais ça s'apprend offert
mesure quoi et tu vois on parle que du
programme
on parle beaucoup du programme on n'est
pas en mode parle de sa part nous de sa
part de ça il ya un truc à mon essai un
peu de voir les limites du sluc voir que
tu vas y à pas tout le monde qui pensent
comme lui que j'ai besoin des vaches du
genre il ya des bouts avec poisson ou
non tu lui dois la pression notamment
parce qu'il y avait des trucs dingues ou
verront quoi c'était assez un peu ouest
un peu particulier avec poisson mais
ouais tu vois il ya pour moi afin là on
se contente de ma vie en général le moi
je fais pas journaliste mais le côté un
peu de contradiction genre
moi ça me semble important donc faut pas
faux pas loin je pense que le jaune et
savants l'incontinence way back youtube
remplace n'en font pas que ça fasse
disparaître le journalisme parce que
c'est mon n'a que les politiques c'est
quand c'est dangereux coiffure est ce
que c'est bien qu'ils aient un espace
libre pour parler c'est très con férence
au fond ça génial mais s'il faut pas que
ça porte il faut pas que ça a aussi un
côté journalistes je pense qu'un mec
comme trump par exemple mais il aurait
gagné de beaucoup plus ouais bah voilà
s'il avait eu sa chance et intubé qui a
eu exactement pour le prochain épisode
je vous laisse répondre à la question
dans les commentaires tu imagines si on
restait jeunes jusqu'à sa mort avait
caramany ce freddy gladieux et panayotis
est-ce que tu as passé un moment super
ça ouais ouais trop cola et j'adore ce
format j'adore le regarder alors
de faire c'est qu'ils font c'est roque
sur cèze a ajouté m merci merci à ceux
qui ont regardé parce que mercy amateurs
de la question aussi
ouais les questions étaient bondées pour
un sujet facile c'était cool j'ai passé
un bon ça m'a aussi franchement merci
m'avoir invité n'hésitez pas à le voir
la chaîne d'hugo hugo décrypte ouais
donc fait vraiment du bon taf et non je
cherchais et c'est cool de qui et
s'assure sur le net je suis content
parce que les gens que j'invite à chaque
fois je kiffe là ouais ouais
désarmé non mais je pense qu'ils j'ai
lancé ma chaîne parce que je pense qu'il
manquait un contenu un traitement à base
journalistique parce que je passe
journalisme et plus objectif et neutre
entre guillemets de l'actualité je dis
pas que c'est nul les trucs engagé mais
je pense qu'il faut un peu de tout et du
coup ouais je fais pas le côté
décryptage j'ai lancé ça et voilà si ça
vous plaît c'est super voilà non ça cool
et voilà merci beaucoup d'être venu la
merced remercie d'être venu chez huawei
voilà deux sur ta chaise ont fait de
gros bisous salue on en voit beaucoup
d'amour à tout ciao ciao bye bye ah la
la